welcome how are you very well mmm good
to see a little annoyed why is that well
30 years and he never once asked me to
be on his show but but I saw you but by
the is not enough no I sold three
records in Sweden because of you okay
you a couple of weeks ago I think you
did in Austin you held speech we last
week last week it was it was much
celebrated and it was a speech about
about rockin about music and it and you
said among other things you said nobody
has anything to say anymore and and I I
hope that was interesting because it was
a quite long speech well it was the
keynote speech and I was asked to speak
for an hour so I had to think of 50
different ways of saying nobody has
anything
one line from the other argument is life
without love is meaningless yep which
seems a very late to realize in the age
of 58 and off
yes I'm slow commerce soft have you
become a softy more understanding it's
not the prerogative of age more
understanding I don't think I'm any
wiser but the truth is that teenagers
and 20 year-olds clearly understand what
it took me a long time to realize that
that maybe John Lennon in all his
naivete was absolutely right you know
all you need is love I mean maybe maybe
that's true
maybe it's very simple to say it and it
took me a long time to understand that
great friends your missus the kids good
food good drink not bad
you get asked about your your former
wife Paula Yates and and because she was
famous as well but if you ask you about
your present wife
I wonder who were you when she came into
your life when Schanke I was somebody
who was detestable somebody unlovable
somebody had their most ugly physically
and spiritually I hated women I didn't
trust them I didn't want to be around
them I had loved my wife she left me I
was destroyed by that I didn't
understand it or anything that was sort
of happening and you inhabit this
universe of pain and grief and loss
crowd your head and you can't function
and my male friends it's different for
women and for people who've been through
this many many people understand women
and their friends deal differently to
men and their friends my male friends
would come along around we just sit
there silently and then they go and they
leave and this was very comforting and
say nothing and and I went to a dinner
in Paris Paris because of all the in in
England unfortunate my family is part of
the National soap opera and so there
were a lot of paparazzi and journalists
permanently outside my house so I'd go
to Paris to to breathe and I had dinner
one night and obstinate was this
beautiful woman but it meant nothing to
me I mean I was the English word is
unmanned I just I registered that here
was a beautiful woman but so what but
she found something lovable in this most
unlovable of men
and your soul when it is reduced to
nothing and there is an insistence on
love gradually inevitably responds and
so the stone song gets stitched back
together again and something resembling
a human being gets reconstructed in this
case me and and that is the dawning
realization of a man approaching a 60s
that to live without love is absurd that
is futile that the human condition
without love being present is a complete
waste of time if we sat here now and
this was a job interview yeah I wouldn't
I wouldn't say that you strike me as a
great organizer if I didn't